et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois blanchecotte il est président
du syndicat national des biologistes
françois blanchecotte bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors on vient donc d'en parler un des
laboratoires font payer pour un résultat
plus rapide on le rappelle c'est une
pratique illégale
est ce que ce sont des cas isolés
comment y remédier alors je pense que ce
sont des cas isolés nous avons appris
cela hier nous avons réagi très
fortement tout de suite en disant que
nous étions pas d'accord du tout même si
ce sont des tests plus rapide
a priori d'après nos renseignements il
ferait neuf patients à l'heure et de les
monnayer en tout cas de les vendre à des
prix prohibitifs
elle nous semble en tout cas illégal je
crois que la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie vient de réagir ce
soir par un communiqué et donc qu'elle
se n'évitera pas peut-être des des
enquêtes en tout cas auprès de ses
laboratoires
toujours est il qu'aujourd'hui ce qui
est important c'est qu'ils aient pas de
discrimination par de l'argent pour
obtenir un test alors on l'a vue là
c'est que interminables devant les
laboratoires un arrêté pris aujourd'hui
par olivier ferrand permet aux agences
régionales de santé de mettre en place
des opérations collectives de dépistage
par test antigénique est ce que c'est
une bonne solution selon vous pour
désengorger les laboratoires alors c'est
un test qui t'a pas comme vous l'avez
souligné très très clairement reçu
encore l'approbation des autorités
scientifiques
c'est un test rapide effectivement mais
c'est un test manuel
ça veut dire que si vous avez un
individu devant vous vous privez lui
rendent en 10 minutes mais 600 personnes
font la queue
ça fait quand même 99 ou sans tests à
faire sur une table c'est pas évident du
tout que ça ne rallonge pas quand même
les délais en tout cas pour les pour
répondre clairement
c'est un test de masse qui n'a pas du
tout la même sensibilité que la rt pcr
il dégrade un peu cette sensibilité ce
qui fait qu'il y aura certains patients
qui pourront passer au travers des
mailles du filet un test moins fiables
dont tiens c'est ça oui si vous voulez
les par là c'est simplement que
100 patients quand tout le monde a du
virus dans le nez la rt pcr de donne
100% de résultats positifs ces tests
donnerait alors selon les sources entre
98 et 95 % c'est-à-dire qu'il y aurait
peut-être quatre où cinq personnes sur
cent qui ne serait pas détecté avec ces
tests alors est ce que les laboratoires
aujourd'hui parviennent à à prioriser
les patients c'est à dire ceux qui
présentent plus de symptômes qui semble
plus malade il ya aussi cette idée de
prioriser ceux qui ont l'appli stop
coville est ce que c'est une bonne idée
alors un petit stock au vide ne n'est
pas n'a pas recueilli en tout cas le
sentiment de beaucoup de français c'est
très très limité sur deux millions de
personnes je crois en ce qui concerne la
priorisation par les symptômes c'est
essentiel pour nous que nous puissions
prendre dans nos laboratoires en
priorité les patients qui ont des
symptômes ducobu
comme vous l'avez souligné les deux
autres catégories aussi mais aussi bien
sûr des gens qui vont être opérés parce
qu' une opération peut pas se repoussent
et donc il ya des cas qu'il faudra
apprécier au cas par cas
il faut ouvrir des plages vous avez
raison pour recevoir ces patients en
priorité les traités et essayer
d'étendre au maximum le dépistage dans d
autres centres de façon à ce que on
limite très fortement c'est que allah la
porte au nez laboratoire mais est-ce que
c'est facile pour le personnel dans les
laboratoires finalement est bien de
trier qu'il faut tester ou pas parce que
finalement on a tous une bonne raison de
venir se faire tester ça peut être un
voyage ça peut être une angoisse on a
tous finalement une bonne raison de
faire la queue oui on a fait des
sondages effectivement aux dires des
patients 72 % environ des patients sont
urgents et à traiter tout de suite
en fait dans la réalité quand on regarde
bien on est plutôt dessous de 30%
donc c'est vrai que nos infirmières pour
les gens qui préleveur étudier au cas
par cas on essaye de voir en tout cas si
les symptômes et 6 1 mais ça nous
adressent quand même une ordonnance avec
marc urgence et qu'on lui fait confiance
et que il faut quand même traité ce
patient en priorité donc c'est difficile
c'est pas aisée pour l'instant nous
avons du retard pour traiter l'ensemble
des dossiers qui sont arrivés à la
rentrée
et tout est arrivé en même temps les
demandes de tout public de toutes sortes
de choses y compris les écoles
vous l'avez vu les étudiants les retours
de vacances les entrées en stage les
vols et c'est donc tout est arrivé en
même temps il n'y a un petit délai dans
lequel on va devoir se rééquiper
fortement de façon a traité plus de
dossiers et essayer de raccourcir ses
attentes
et est ce que les laborantins vont
pouvoir tenir sur la durée selon vous
alors c'est un vrai problème que l'on a
rendez vous demain en commission branche
avec les délégués nationaux parce que
vous l'avez remarqué il ya eu des
insultes qui ont été faits beaucoup
d'agressions contre à beaucoup de gens
se sont libérés des mots qui sont tous
souvent insupportable pour des gens qui
sont sur le pont depuis le mois de
février
on n'a pas eu beaucoup de répit pendant
pendant tous ces six mois qui sont
passés et donc aujourd'hui il ya un peu
un ras-le-bol c'est vrai vous l'avez dit
les gens sont fatigués il y en a
certains qui sont mis en arrêt de
travail
il ya certains sites aujourd'hui qui
sont en grève donc on voit bien quand
même que il faut pas épuiser les
ressources de nos personnels parce que
ça risque de d'allonger encore plus les
délais pour rendre les résultats
alors la france est désormais le
troisième pays d'europe qui dépistent le
plus au monde avec un million de tests
par semaine la stratégie n'est pas
efficace pour autant on le répète
souvent alors est ce que c'est un échec
finalement moi je pense que l'échec
majeur c'était la sortie du confinement
ce jour là il aurait fallu que tout ce
post à masquer que l'on n'applique
vraiment les gestes barrière aujourd'hui
si vous voulez quelqu'un qui vient une
personne sur 4 bien pour se rassurer
parce qu'elle a été en contact mais il
faut compter aussi sur le comportement
au civisme de chaque français
si demain vous venez de vous faire
tester vous est négatif et vous avez un
comportement à risque
ça veut dire que dans une semaine je
vais vous revoir dans le laboratoire
donc ça en condroz d'autant les files
d'attentes des gens qui n'ont jamais eu
de test
d'autre part il ya un phénomène qui est
très important à savoir nous portons
virus des fois pendant plusieurs
semaines dans les narines et nous avons
des gens qui reviennent systématiquement
toutes les semaines parce que leur
employeur leur demande
d'un test négatif pour revenir au
travail donc on voit que dans toutes ses
filles datant il ya aussi des gens qui
reviennent vix fois ce qui complique la
situation encore plus pour prendre les
gens la première fois merci beaucoup
françois blanchecotte d'avoir répondu à
nos questions rappelle que vous êtes
président président du syndicat national
des biologistes